foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to this edition of i'd
like to know one of our favorite
programs here at some tv i am c.a murray
and i'm in the company of my
fellow panelists pastor daniel miranda
daniel good to have you here thank you
good to be here
we enjoy studying the word of god
together i guess you know that by now
and we enjoy this program because it uh
encourages us moves us to study the word
of god and then to reach out to you
for your questions which you are sending
in aplenty we have an impressive list of
questions in english
and uh and in spanish
and we're working our way through the
english ones and daniel has been tasked
with doing the spanish questions and is
doing a very very fine job
should you like to send in a question
sid should you like to be part of this
rather impressive list you can do so by
sending your bible-based questions
to tv
at some tv dot o-r-g that's tv
at some tv
dot
g o-r-g-n we will uh put them in the
pile and get to them just as soon as we
can we promise you that we will get to
them sometimes it may seem as though
they are a long time in coming
but uh fear fear not we will get to them
uh
and we want to take as much time as we
feel is necessary to answer each
question so we're not necessarily going
for speed
we're trying to go for accuracy in the
word of god and for understanding so
that your questions are answered as
thoroughly as we can and of course we
make you this promise always that if an
answer can be found we will find that
answer in the word of god and get it
right to you so thank you in advance for
sending your questions and uh we're
getting questions from all
as far as china and all places in
between so we are quite pleased that um
questions are coming in
literally from all over the world and we
promise you we'll get to them uh as soon
as we possibly can daniel if you would
speak to the lord on our behalf in
prayer remember we will move out and
begin the program
let us bow heads for prayer
dear heavenly father
once again we come before you because we
want to ask for your wisdom we want to
ask for your enlightenment
we thank you lord for this program for
our brethren there that send us the
questions
you know lord that they want to
sincerely find answers
and we pray that you may help us
give them the answers that they need in
the name of jesus i pray amen amen amen
now danny this question from peter did
this come into you
uh
in your personal email or did this come
through the regular
the regular um well it's tv at some tv
so it did come in
i know we have a couple questions
that um
actually came to you
but uh an interesting question
uh when the lost are resurrected
what will they be closed with and what
will they eat
peter henderson
this is one of those interesting kind of
nuancy questions you get every now and
again
what comes to your mind because we've
got so much about
those who are resurrected who are saved
and of course uh
the bible doesn't give us intimate
or intricate detail
about the lost but we we do know some
things so what do you got
well you know um
we don't we don't want to go as far as
speculating from the word of god in
those details
um
we you know the the resurrection is such
a supernatural act of god
that to try to explain how exactly they
will come off from the graves
uh will be to speculate but the the
bible gives us a pretty pretty fair idea
of of that of the resurrection for
example in first corinthians chapter 15
and now this is not speaking of the lost
but paul gives here a principle
and in regards to the
in regards to the righteous
uh we find here he uses the the example
of the seed and let me try to find out
here's first corinthians chapter 15
and um
and i'm going to read verse
30 35 and onward it says but someone
will say how are the dead raised up
and with what body do they come
it's a similar question
verse 36 foolish one
what you saw is not made alive unless it
dies
and what you saw
you do not saw that body that shall be
but mere grain perhaps wheat or some
other grain
but god gives it a body
as he pleases
and to each seed its own body
all flesh is not the same flesh
but there is one kind of flesh of man
and another flesh of an of animals
another a fish
and another of birds
there are also celestial bodies and
terrestrial bodies
but the glory of the celestial one
is one and the glory of the terrestrial
is another
there is one glory of the sun another
glory of the moon and another glory of
the stars for one star differs from the
another starring glory so
also is the resurrection of the dead
the body is shown in corruption
it is raised in incorruption so that's
the point i wanted to get to
so speaking of the righteous
there is a principle that paul draws
from nature from the planting of the
seed
when you plant
a
a corn
what you get is not the same thing
it's a different it's a different body
it's a plant you know first
first the
the the leaf the spear
then
uh you have first the blade
then the ear then the the corn in the
ear okay that's what you get it's very
different from what you planted
now in the case of the lust
they will resurrect the same way they
went to the grave
because they will not experience
this uh change of being sown in
corruption being raised in corruption
okay that's okay that's what you're
heading that's i was waiting for you to
get there i knew you're coming
because that's what was in my mind
having
done my last church i did 117 funerals
so i went to first corinthians when you
said first corinthians 15 you could see
my note first corinthians 15. if you
stay with this long enough you get to
the bodies of the righteous but here's
the thing and and and this is where you
headed i apologize for cutting you along
no no
that
the
the going down in corruption
and coming up incorruptible
is a miracle of god yes it is that
happens because god interposes to change
our corruptable bodies to incorruptible
bodies
those who are lost
don't get that miracle
so what they go down with
they come up with exactly the you know
the the change the white robes the
change are are for the redeemed
and if you're not redeemed you don't get
to change
so whatever you went down with
you come up with now that that has to do
with mindset
motives
uh the way you approach life
i suspect what clothes you went down
with you'll come up with you know
but but we know that mentally and and
and spiritually you're going to be the
same you're going to be the same corrupt
person that that died in corruption so
that gives us you know in jeremiah
it talks about that day
they're not going to be mourned they're
not going to be buried they're not going
to you know um
god's energies are not at this point are
not going to be for those who are lost
all energy is going to be for those who
are saved amen uh so
it's it's an interesting question but
it's a a question that that's kind of
well
the bible doesn't exactly explain it but
that's not where god's focus is
god's focus is now and will always be on
those who follow him and who love him
and who are going to be changed in a
moment
in the twinkling of an eye amen and
that's the group that i want to be in
amen maybe the closest
quote that we have in regards to that is
in great controversy pages 663 and 664.
this is the last chapter the controversy
ended
and ellen y here speaking directly and
specifically about the resurrection of
the lost and she says
uh speaking of satan he makes the weak
strong
and inspires all with his own spirit and
energy
so she asked what are they going to eat
you know the earth has been desolate for
a thousand years there is no food
well satan is going to
make them strong and he's going to
inspire them
with his spirit and energy they won't
have any need to eat
he proposed to lead them against the
camp of the saints and to take profits
possession of the cities i want to go to
the next chapter it says in that vast
throng are multitudes of the long lead
race that existed before the flood men
of lofty stature etc etc
and then
here it says
this is the key part
let me see as they come up from the
grave
they resume the current of their
thoughts just where it sees
they are actuated by the same desire to
conquer
that rule them when they fail
so
there is no change yes in the lost when
they resurrect
the same way they went to the grave the
same way they when they fail it is the
same way they will resurrect
yeah the same hate the same malignity
the same evil
it just kind of picks up where it left
off yes and uh there is no miraculous
change in anything
because
they're not saved so god does not work
to change anything because there there
would be no need to do that correct uh
nothing to be gained by doing that an
interesting question uh and the bible
does give us along with the spirit of
prophecy some light does not give us
thorough light but
let's put our energy shall we say in the
in the in the other camp
certainly to be in the other camp and uh
to be saved and to hear the well done
from the lips of american savior
amen
alrighty
this next one comes from christopher
decosta
and um
deals with some
nuances some variances in the king james
version as opposed to other translations
you want to read that one daniel
says i'm struggling reconciling the king
james version errors in translation with
the other translations on revelation 5
verses 9 and 10.
why does revelation 5 10
use
help me with that
the word oh um
while others use potatoes
how to explain these use without
indirectly discouraging someone's
confidence in god's word
well i think you're the greek scholar
here pastor
i'm like the angel in revelation 19. say
not so
it's been a long time since we did a a
lot of study in greeks
we could have used pastor boar for this
uh having having said that um
i did some some research hey moss
means us
we us it's possessive and it's a very
strong
word uh as far as emphasis is concerned
but interestingly enough he is correct
um only the the
king james right uses that
um
the others uh
use autos or octus
and so we see this as an anomaly in the
king james there are some words
that came through in the king james that
we find no place else right and
when you find one over here and
everybody else is over here then you
gotta think of that one as an outlier
we we do not say that every word every
preposition uh in the king james is
inspired by god
the
the thoughts of the bible are inspired
by god because god inspired the minds of
those who wrote them but
every
a or an or the
may not be accurate as it should now one
because there are slight anomalies
slight changes in
one text of the bible should not deflate
your confidence
in the word of god
as
a book that should control your thoughts
and your practices
and the way you you
approach god and the way you follow him
if you find a small grammatical error or
a small
uh grammatical change
don't let that cast away your confidence
in god as the
director of your life
um
if the bible says remember the sabbath
day
to keep it holy six days shalt i live
and do all thy work
that's
truth
that should be followed
if there's a uh in there that shouldn't
be or a misplaced
uh
comma or something don't let that cast
all your confidence in the word of god
as a rule of faith and practice
that's what's important and that's what
should be taken away from the study of
the word of god amen amen precisely
the bible commentary that we have here
confirms what you just said pastor ca
that the king james translators
inserted that word as or or
heyus
they inserted it from the latin vulgate
but in the masoretic text
we don't find
that word but actually
in the new international
version and in the new king james
version
it's instead of us
it says them
actually in the new
the new international version it says
you have made them to be a kingdom and
priest to serve our god in the new king
james version it also says us
but here
in this one in the new international
version it says you have made
them and this makes more sense with the
context of revelation chapter four and
five
here speaking about 24 elders
and if we say
that they're singing you have made us
then that gives
some
argument
to conclude that they are humans
but
it is more uh clear when it says you
have made them
which implies that is referring to the
saved yes if you are moving along in the
study of the word of god and you find a
little sharp left turn that is
unjustified then one of the reasons that
uh one of the blessings of having
several translations is you can compare
translation with translation
the the king james translators had uh
fairly good manuscripts but there's been
much discovered since then yes uh
nothing to change
what the bible says about how we should
live our lives but will you find some
grammatical anomalies will you find some
things that are slightly different yes
you will uh because uh much of our
scholarship today is based on more
recent discoveries of more ancient texts
so
uh i i think the person is worried about
uh someone losing confidence in god's
word he states that
um
the bible says cast not away therefore
your confidence
an uh
as opposed to a
is not going to change how you should
serve the lord uh it's not gonna change
the ten commandments it's not gonna
change god's will for your life amen um
so
don't toss out the baby with the bath
water because you find a little mistake
uh in in grammar or in syntax um and
that's why the bible says study to show
themselves the proof all of the gold in
the bible is not found on the surface
you got to dig you got to spend a little
time and if you dig what you'll find by
digging is that your confidence in the
word of god increases
it does not decrease
and you know that as far as your faith
and your practice is concerned it is
unerring the word is a lamp unto our
feet and a light unto our past amen
amen
all right so thank you christopher for
that you know we've got some very good
bible students uh in our in our
viewership that we do yeah we do
let's see denise is the next one
yes denise denise
so the question is summarize at the end
yes
um
basically the question is
is it biblical for pastors to shout at
the congregation when they preach
it's a long question and this is the
summary of the question yes apparently
the sister here has a
has a difference of opinion with her
pastor
and her pastor says that it is okay to
shout he himself shouts when he preaches
and he sustains that with mark
10 verse 46 to 52 when bartimaeus
was shouting
to christ
so
that is basically the question
so much of what we do
in the name of the lord is cultural
i come from a tradition
where
pastor shout
and
when i am
in the presence of a congregation that
is responding to me
by shouting
i shout more yes
it's my nature i and i
i shout at basketball games
i shout at
sporting events
i shout when i'm happy
i shout in the presence of the lord
i tend
to like
my sermons
with a little cayenne
i think if you believe in something
you put a little fire behind it right a
little energy in it and i'm not i'm i'm
giving my personal opinion i've got some
texts that i may come up with
in a moment but i'm i'm i'm talking
about the
the cultural history that i have come
from
i come from a history of call and
response
it goes back to africa if you look at
the african plain songs if you look at
the african
work song it was call and response
someone calls and the congregation
responds yes so when i am
uh
in the presence of call and response i'm
i'm most comfortable i've had the proof
of preaching around the world
and
years ago i preached in new zealand
and um
full church
and i was preaching and the church was
silent the only voice was mine
and
they were so silent i thought either
they're not getting it or they're not
hearing me so i think i'll just amp it
up a little bit more so i did
uh still no response
so i amped it up a little bit more and
nothing
at the end of the sermon i was standing
until people shaking my hands and
the comments were so profuse
i asked one fellow i said
no one said anything no one
responded he said yeah we responded he
said but we feel it's rude to respond
while a preacher is preaching
so you would never get us to verbally
respond but if you look at the eyes and
if you look at the nodding of the head
you know we're with you and and that was
true well that was that culture
uh that was that they don't respond
because i think it's rude to to talk
back during a preacher where uh i've i
grew up in a church when from the time
that pastor says good morning people are
talking back to them you know they're
they're giving it back to them and and
you're getting it back i preached in
romania several years ago when i started
the the series people were quiet they
weren't talking to me but by the end of
the series they were right you know i
kind of trained them
i was going to have that new zealand
experience again i kind of trained them
and the pastor told me they like it they
like that they like that so it a lot of
it is cultural um
i don't think the the the
the bible says that you should be a
whispering hope or that you should shout
but um
if it's if it's fire shut up in your
bones when it comes out it comes out
with some force right it tends not to
just leak out it kind of leaps out
and that's that's the history that i
have
interesting you know i appreciate your
your input because
um you come from that background and
that culture and we should not address
this
uh for just from one perspective
and you're right
i come from a different culture
where we tend at least in my region uh
people tend to be more passive yes so
they do not respond much to very
enthusiastically sermons but
they like to more think meditate
and the slower you speak you know the
better for them yes so i come from that
different background
and uh
and i have tried to i've gone to places
for example i went to africa to the
congo
and over there i was
trying to preach and
very soft and slow and now people wanted
some something stronger
and so i learned that you have to adapt
the way you preach
depending on
at least in my case what i learned
depending on your audience
but definitely
uh there are some principles i don't
know if we have time for that
that we find
in in in revelation in inspiration
when it comes to
to preaching
uh so for example
uh in the voice and speech and song
[Music]
ellen white speaks
or she tries to correct
uh
when ministers speak in a very very high
pitch that um i believe
you you presented it very balanced
because it's it's okay to be
enthusiastic it's okay to be passionate
about uh what you're preaching and there
might be some moments that you have to
raise your voice and that's part of the
homological
uh delivery of of the sermon but um
we are
another thing is screaming
and i think this is what lmy is warning
against yes when she says here for
example by talking
in a high key the speaker detracts
considerably from his useful usefulness
there are others who talk
and this is the other extreme there are
others who talk so low
that the words can can scarcely be hurt
another laborer will will speak
hurriedly
rushing his words one upon another
half
that he says is lost
for the hearer cannot take in the
precious words coming from his lips
there are defects which should be
overcome yes you know
there is this this remembrance of ellen
white speaking
uh in a fairly large auditorium and it
was raining on a metal roof
and her voice could be heard over that
patapat on on a metal roof so she spoke
she spoke with with um
uh with force i remember uh
my dear friend who's passed now pastor
c.d brooks said that the
the
the ethic are not suffer under the
weight of the ethnic
so
you you don't want to get so much into
your ethnicity ethnicity
that you
neglect uh
the the clear preaching of the word the
bible says it ought to have a certain
sound there ought to be a certain ring
there are and of course that's talking
about doctrinal truth but i think we can
extend that without doing violence to
the text to say that the word of god has
to be delivered in a way that first of
all is palatable to the people it's
understood by the people which lifts
them up not tears them down and if you
you violate any of those things you're
defeating the purpose for standing in
the pulpit yeah uh if they're not being
edified if they're not being informed if
they're not being inspired then why are
you there so you must do those things
that mitigate in favor of those things
um and and and do it with enough energy
that uh
the saints of god aren't sleeping on you
and
they're getting the word of god and
they're getting you with power and
authority amen yes
amen
well um we're down to our last several
seconds again these are good questions
we appreciate these questions we
appreciate the times when you
send in questions and we are trying to
get to each and every one of them um
tv at some tv.org
is the address that you can send your
questions to and uh today we only got
through a couple some
times we get through three sometimes we
get through four sometimes only one but
we want to be as thorough and as we can
and the speed is not the issue
thoroughness is an accuracy to the word
of god well our time has fast slipped
into eternity we'll see you again next
time god bless and goodbye
[Music]
you